wait what I have no idea somebody wanna
tell me something
[Music]
twenty thirty thirty twenty six twenty
nine twenty seven twenty nine ninety six
twenty four twenty seven twenty five my
wife my wife what what my Korean age uh
what does that even mean I don't know
what that question means I don't know
I'm 31 in Korean 28 in Korea I'm 25 25
27 I'm 25 in Korean age I'm 24 I'm 2063
they're different they have different
ages that I think why how does that work
[Music]
[Music]
oh wow okay that's crazy that makes
sense
some older I'm just getting over the
fact that I just heard 2016 ooh like
give me a second a bucket dress it's a
before you tell her honey it's Evan well
how about that legal in my home country
you got to give me all the booze
[Music]
for my age here cuz I'm younger I like
24 better than 25 I prefer my age here I
am younger here wants to be older unless
you're like 12 oh I like my age here I'm
gonna stick with 30 I want to be young
forever I need about half the year I
have left to feel okay about 30 I'm glad
I'm in America their music is too like
mind-blowing bet you age a little bit
that's how cool Koreans are they have
their own age